i hope you don't get caught i won't
growing up in the internet age has made
sleuthing second nature to us 90s kids
any information that we could possibly
want is at our fingertips on our feeds
or being chatted about amongst our
circle of friends
one topic however has eluded the public
eye for some time
the olsen twins literally this has been
our life and this is you know natural to
us
it would be difficult to reminisce about
growing up in the 90s without mentioning
perhaps our fave twin duo of all time
mary kate and ashley olsen so officially
have they made their place in history
and
our hearts that simply saying mary kate
and ashley without their famous last
name
most people would know who you're
talking about so what makes them the
picture of nostalgia
and why were they constantly on our
minds today we're going to take a
journey down the olsen twin maze
to find out why mary kate and ash have
piqued our interest for all these years
while we don't see them often if at all
in the public spotlight and where they
are now in 2020 so we can finally put
our worried minds to rest
let's hope by the end of this
investigation we won't need to get the
free the olson's hashtag trending
adams don't be daft now
where's my little sis getting their
start as taking turns playing michelle
tanner on full house
mk and ash entered the entertainment
industry at the very young age
of nine months following the massive
success of the series during the seven
year streak
the twins ventured off into the movie
world under their own production company
which developed 47 films in the early
2000s
in addition to their classic movies it
takes two passport to paris and new york
minute to name a few
they also starred in their own tv series
released to music and magazines and
began building their fashion empire
all in their pre-teens in a 2013
interview
ashley told wwd we couldn't see over the
top of the table
i always looked at myself even as a kid
as a businesswoman with mary kate adding
i don't think it ever felt like we were
actresses
because we spent so much of our time not
in front of the cameras building a brand
i hope you guys enjoy the show and the
collection it's easy to see how simply
their presence in their many public
ventures
made it almost difficult for us not to
notice and be interested in the empire
these twins were building in the 90s and
early 2000s following the explosion of
their career however
the twins both fell very silent as they
inched into their 20s
aside from a handful of interviews
throughout the 2010s
the question on everyone's mind shifted
to what happened to the olsen twins
i hope this year is one of the best ones
yet unlike many of their celeb peers
the twins are not on any social media
platforms there are no tweets
posts or status updates to keep their
names buzzing in our ears
most of the media surrounding mk and ash
come from rare paparazzi sightings
or sparse interviews with the women that
are primarily focused on their fashion
brands
it's not a trend it's not a trend based
brand
this definitely makes it difficult to
keep tabs on what they're doing and
what's going on in their life
in 2017 ashley said we don't dive into
that world of social media we don't have
instagram or facebook so we've never
been connected to our customers or fans
in
that way we've stayed quite sheltered
the only single occurrence where the
sisters have been directly involved on
social media is their infamous selfie in
collaboration with sephora as a takeover
the photo features the twins making
their usual stoic face
wearing black sunglasses and with the
caption first public selfie ever this
lack of social platform and interaction
with fans is almost
unheard of in our media connected world
it also means that they are essentially
void of public scrutiny as they do not
often share personal opinions or beliefs
on topics in social media that might be
criticized by the masses
in this way the twins legacy is almost
pristine in our nostalgic minds
we remember them always as the innocent
and sweet twin duo who had a lot of
sauce and personality
i'm sorry is someone talking because i
don't hear anyone
married life has its own separate
demands with mary kate saying in 2017
that i have a husband two step kids and
a life i have to go home and cook
dinner i ride horses on the weekends she
has to balance her fashion empire with
her sister ashley
and try to lead a normal life with her
husband olivier sarkozy
between all of those demands it makes
sense that mary kate leans on the quiet
side of celebrity
while ashley differs from her sister in
the married realm of life she's been
spotted often throughout the years
meeting with various business investors
for their fashion company
some of which had the world speculating
romantic undertones
ash's team confirmed though that they
were purely professional
although ashley does have a well-known
past of sporadic dating with a handful
of men
same with her sister mary kate since
2017
ashley's been dating la based artist
louis eisner no news has come to the
surface to reveal the seriousness
of their relationship but it seems to
occupy much of ashley's free time
how can i find you call her 555-8989
the latest public sighting of the twins
was in july 2020
following mk's seemingly messy divorce
with olivier sarkozy
lasting five years and involving
stepchildren the couple
called it quits in may and resulted in
olivier kicking mk
out of their living quarters in new york
in a rare sighting mary kate and ashley
were seen outside their manhattan hq for
the rope with mk seemingly jumping back
into work also per sources
neither mary kate or sarkozy have
released any official statement about
their separation but the paparazzi have
been all over it with speculations and
judgments
in explicit situations like these the
olsen's decision to live an almost
anonymous life in the public eye begins
to make more sense
it becomes really dangerous first of all
and um
yeah everybody wants a good story when
the news broke that netflix was
developing a full house spin-off fuller
house
slated to stream in 2016 our minds
instantly asked one question
will all the cast be returning for this
nostalgic reboot unfortunately
the olsen twins were nowhere in sight
during the show and were only mentioned
a handful of times in a sort of
passively joking manner
at these prices no wonder they don't
need to act anymore although the
producers and showrunners all gave it
their best attempt to bring the twins to
set
mk and ash declined several times
resulting in the crew backing off
the only information we have is a
personal account from one of the
producers
who relayed that ashley had said that
since she had not been in front of a
camera since she was 17
she simply didn't feel comfortable being
part of it while mary kate added that it
just wasn't a good time for them
aside from the joking remarks about a
missing michelle tanner the show did
manage to excuse their absence from the
show by saying michelle was busy running
a fashion label in nyc
a nod to the twins reality and reason
for absence
well michelle sends her love but she's
busy in new york running her
fashion empire following their
back-to-back movie releases in the early
2000s
mary kate and ashley have not been
active on the screen only appearing in a
handful of films over a 10-year span
mary kate's latest solo acting gig was
in 2011's beastly where she portrayed
the villain ashley on the other hand
appeared solo in jared leto's music
video with 30 seconds to mars in 2013.
together the twins were seen in the 2013
documentary series scatter my ashes at
bergdorf's which is their last
public appearance on film i think
burgers has been
really supportive in addition to ashley
not feeling comfortable being in front
of the camera the twins seem to directly
oppose being the center of attention in
general it would appear that anything on
camera or
media related is off the table for the
twins following their massively public
2000 stardom in that 2017
interview when asked about posing in
their own brand of clothing for
magazines
mary kate answered with we're used to
being on the other side of the camera
and managing the process so it's hard
for us to do photo shoots now
in speculating this response there's
definitely a been there done that vibe
that has had an impact on their level of
comfort being in the public eye too much
of a good thing could be the reason
behind their very direct and intentioned
decision to remove themselves from the
spotlight in an interview with l uk
ashley confirmed her dislike for the
screen saying i don't like to be the
center of attention anymore it doesn't
mean i'm not interested in hollywood
i like the way it operates i like the
people who are involved and the sense of
possibility but if i ever get back in
it's not going to be as an actress it
just took me a
few wrong turns to see it from what we
know most of the olsen twins time is
spent perfecting and pushing the
boundaries on their two fashion labels
luxury brand the row and contemporary
lifestyle brand elizabeth and james
acting as both the founders and
designers for these two very different
labels
it's easy to understand how these two
can be so busy that they've eluded the
public eye
what may seem like an odd segue from the
film industry to fashion
upon further inspection it was actually
a natural transition for the pair
due to the amount of fittings and
outfits that they were constantly put
into
as ashley said we've been in so many
fittings we used to do two a week for 15
years
mary kate added to the sentiment by
confirming saying when we were younger
being in the public eye was almost part
of our role and responsibility to set
the trends at that time or
be ahead of fashion we would take adult
clothing and cut it down to our size
change the proportions both mk and ash
are serious about the image of their
brand and putting out a product that
they can be proud of the success of both
their brands has resulted in them being
awarded a handful of accolades in recent
years
including women's wear designers of the
year in 2012 and 2015 and accessory
designers of the year by the council of
fashion designers of america
in both 2014 and 2018. well thank you
we were not expecting this while the
lives of the olsen twins is still very
much a mystery
we're happy to confirm that they haven't
vanished no free the olson's hashtag
needed
the extreme stardom to hermit behavior
that mary kate and ashley have exhibited
seem to be a result of public burnout
with their two diverse fashion brands
receiving awards and the sisters seeming
to speak passionately about their brand
we can sleep well knowing that they're
doing okay even if mk is in the middle
of a divorce
so when the olsen twins ask to give us
some space and distance from their
private lives
the only real way to answer is you got
it dude can't wait to meet you soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you